and I have talked about the problems
with campaign consultants over 15 20
years what finally got you to the point
where you said I've got to write a book
about this I think I began to think
about it after the 2000 campaign and
certainly after the 2004 campaign it
just seemed that the the system had
gotten so over to the side of of
politicians being programmed the lack of
spontaneity had gotten to be so
spectacular that and I think there was
one conversation that actually did it it
was a conversation that I had with a
with Al Gore's consultants after the
2000 election and and I asked them
Wendy talk more about the environment
he's really passionate about that and
they said we told him not to I said why
did you tell him not to they said well
we couldn't get another vote talking
about the environment he had to talk
about the Democratic Party evergreens
health education and jobs and I said but
wait a second you know he was a stiff
talking about those things what would
have happened if he had been able to
talk about things that he was really
passionate about like global warming
wouldn't have been a better more
effective candidate and Tad divine one
of the consultants said that's an
interesting thought so I figured you
know it's time but I've been doing this
I've been doing this for 37 years and I
want to tell the audience a secret about
both you and me and many of our
colleagues we don't continue to do this
because we're cynics I don't do it to
watch them screw up although that
sometimes fun I do it because well first
of all it's an addiction and there
aren't any 12-step programs for
political junkies but also because I
really want to I do it for the moments
when they do the tough things when they
tell an inconvenient truth or come up
with something spontaneous a new
location a new way of saying things that
is that
exciting or when they inspire me in some
way or when they're human in some other
way and increasingly as you know I mean
you wrote a whole book about the early
stages of a political campaign because
those are the only stages where
spontaneous things happen and that doing
a book on 2008 is impossible because the
dominant figure in the Democratic Party
when Hillary Clinton would not allow a
moment of spontaneity to happen and if
and if there was a moment of spontaneity
there'd be 732 TV cameras recording it
that's right that's right and and and
for that reason I hate I hate making
predictions but I will predict that the
the current frontrunner in both parties
may not be the frontrunner I mean I
really believe one of the reasons to do
this now is I think that we're reaching
a critical mass I think that when a
politician comes to the country and says
something like rather than a policy of
Family Values we need policies that
value families I heard that I've heard
that people know that that's nonsense
that it's baloney that it that no human
being no regulation-size human being
ever talks like that and my guess is
what's the opposite of a working family
well that was you know that was a great
John Kerry dodge this was one of the
secret divisions within the Democratic
Party for many years New Democrats
talked about middle-class families old
Democrats talked about working-class
families and you could always kind of
sense which side of the street a
candidate was playing John Kerry talked
about middle-class and working families
so those families that married well
right you know I had hopes for him in
the beginning when he talked about what
he was going in for his prostate cancer
surgery and he and he said that he hoped
that they would also remove his aloof
gland but apparently they didn't so it
was a big problem
but going back up to the whole notion of
consultants which is first of all I have
to when you talked about the consultants
not allowing gore
to talk about what he wanted to talk
about I have to tell a Bob Shrum story
I'll check II self-funded candidates for
governor of California in 1998 who used
Bob Shrum who was a big figure in your
book as one of his major consultants
spent 2025 million dollars to finish
third in a primary in TV ads and I was
out in California about three days
before the primary doing the obligatory
interview with Jack yeah I said what's
your biggest frustration with this
campaign he said well I have all these
ideas for California but I can't express
them in a 30-second ad I said excuse me
you're paying for this campaign did you
ever tell your consultants that maybe
like Ross Perot I'd like to buy a half
an hour somewhere to actually express a
complicated thought it was like I said
why didn't you wear antlers on TV it was
it was just so they are so in the sway
of consultants well the bad candidates
are consultants make bad candidates
worse good candidates know how to good
politicians know when to listen and when
not to listen you know Reagan certainly
Clinton you know Dick Morris said to
Clinton in 1996 you're not gonna win
this election unless you change your
position and oppose affirmative action
well Clinton looked at the numbers
Clinton was addicted to the numbers
obviously he spent gazillions of dollars
on polling and thought about it and said
no I can't do that and you know that's
what a good politician will do speaking
of good politicians actually I think one
of them wonderful details in this book
is that I never knew that Harry Truman
coming before the 1948 Democratic
convention in Philadelphia memory serves
and lived his acceptance his entire
acceptance speech I mean this was the
most important moment of Harry Truman's
political life he was the incumbent
president having gotten there when
Franklin Franklin Roosevelt died and
seemed overwhelmed by the job and Thomas
Dewey was the Far Away favorite the
Democratic Party had shattered into a
left-wing progressive party led by Henry
Wallace and a right-wing Dixiecrat party
led by Strom Thurmond nobody thought
Truman had a chance he goes to the
convention he Chuck's aside his speech
and he talks like for the first time in
public on the national stage talks of
like the guy he is which is a small
Missouri Dirt Farmer and at the climax
of the speech he calls the Republican
Congress back to Washington to pass the
things that they say that they're in
favor of and he and he says I want them
to come back on July 26th which out in
Missouri we called turnip day now that's
the kind of thing that would never ever
get into a speech nowadays
note the speechwriter would think about
doing it it was a reflection of Harry
Truman's humanity it was a little hook
that gave the public a sense of who this
guy is
and it was really the spiritual heart of
what became to give them hell Harry
Campaign or give em hell em everything
and why don't more candidate just say
this is my campaign I'm gonna win I'm
gonna lose it on my own by the way the
irony about that that turnip day story
is that Bob Shrum was the one who told
it to me oh you know and and you know
the question is why has Bob Shrum Shrum
throughout his career taken those
moments away I catch me probably for
those the uninitiated who have not spent
as many years worrying about who's going
to win the New Hampshire primary is we
have maybe we should back off and you
can just explain who Bob Shrum is well
Bob Shrum for the last couple of cycles
has been you know the ultimate
Democratic consultant started off as a
speechwriter he's an excellent speech
writer has been involved in presidential
campaigns eight
I think he's unfairly people unfairly
say that he's been involved in eight
presidential campaigns and lost them all
but you know you can't blame McGovern on
Bob
from he was a kid you know and I think
that you know he he was involved in the
Gebhard campaign in 88 which in and in
some ways he resuscitated that campaign
with its populist message and with the
and with one ad the Hyundai the Hyundai
ad and then in 1992 he served Bob Kerry
disastrously and with roughly the same
ad for totally different candidate right
and although Bob Kerry said to me that
the really bad ad was him in a sterile
hospital room talking about health care
and he said to me people looked at that
ad and they were and they were thinking
I don't want to be anywhere near that
Kerry said it was the only time you'd
ever put a buy an advertising buy up on
the air and his poll ratings went down
but then you know from infamously was
the was the you know the motivating
force them the lead consultant on both
the gore and Kerry campaigns now you
know I I don't blame the gore and Kerry
campaigns on Bob Shrum I by I blame them
on gore and Kerry as you were saying the
key here is that the politicians will
give over will assign their conscience
and theirs and their common sense over
their consultants which in part is a
consequence of the fact that these
things build so quickly and the velocity
is so great and they're so intense that
it is very difficult to keep your head
on straight if you're if you're a
candidate you're just moving from event
to event kind of like being on book tour
but but it is ultimately their
responsibility you know it's up to Al
Gore to say no I want this campaign to
be about global warming or even I want
this campaign to be about what you want
and global warming right because you
know a lot of times polling isn't a bad
thing consultants aren't a bad thing I
have a whole chapter in the book about
Mavericks who I tend to
you know I tend to love Mavericks
because they actually speak English and
and and yet they never win and that's
because they don't have the kind of
infrastructure consultant infrastructure
to tell them to give them a sense of
perspective you know Clinton would say a
lot of times he'd look at the polls and
he'd say oh that's what they're
interested in and that's what they favor
and so it's good for me to know that and
that's good because I kind of like those
things too and I'll talk about those
things what politicians don't do and
what they have to make the judicious
choice on is what things to talk about
that the public isn't interested in the
things that are important to them that
the public doesn't yet care about that
you want the public altum Utley to care
about because especially in television
age this is a job where you're part of
the job description is to educate the
country
I mean Franklin Roosevelt you know the
the stories that our parents told us
about Franklin Roosevelt telling them to
go out and buy maps during World War two
so that they could follow our troops
George Bush george w bush could have
done something similar to that after
September 11th but he chose not to be
the educator in chief Oh before uh
before we get into Bush I want to go
back to one of the most interesting
things about well hold up the book what
the header politics lost and that is
that from the tenor of this I can to
agree with you that the Democrats are
more bedeviled by Republicans in recent
years than Republicans in recent years
by consultants and I'm trying to get at
the why it's a difficult why in part it
is that the Democrats have had a tougher
tougher sell since the 1960s
because because of the the Honorable
position that they took on the civil
right on civil rights and they've added
therefore taking in the South off the
board which was always the Democratic
bailiwick and presidential
yeah and also taking the working-class
North off the board ultimately when they
supported of things like affirmative
action and forced busing and so they
would ask their Republicans essentially
asked to things of their consultants
they asked them to find the right words
and then they'd ask them to bash
Democrats Democrats asked consultants to
find the right words but they also asked
them to figure out ways to finesse their
positions on issues so they're in favor
of racial preferences but not quotas and
on issue after issue you could listen to
Hubert Humphrey talking about school
busing in 1968 and he sounds very much
like John Kerry talking about Iraq in
2004 but the main I was on that bus
before I got off that body right I'm on
that bus sometimes under these
circumstances and therefore you know
Ronald Reagan gave the Republican Party
an incredible gift which was simple
sentences or sentence fragments strong
military low taxes traditional values
Democrats of the party of the compound
sentence we need to invest in head start
in order to get a better educated and
more stable you know that's or isn't the
Democratic compound sentence a little
different while I hear your concern
about that's a different one in that
that's absolutely it and underlying that
is a different philosophy of what
elections are about a presidential
elections Democrats tend to believe that
they're about issues Republicans tend to
believe they're about character and when
they're about character that also means
destroying the character of the Democrat
and so going back to the 1930s
Republicans have believed you know the
first Republican consultant shop in
California you know believe that the the
campaigns were you know we're about
entertainment and about keeping the
folks entertained Richard Nixon
certainly intimidated a lot of Democrats
as you were saying before in 1972 and
when Karl Rove comes in to organize the
Bush campaign in 2000 he says there are
three questions
who's the stronger candidate who's more
trustworthy who cares more about people
like me and I don't think the Democrats
have ever had a meeting about a
presidential campaign that was as
straightforward and as simple as that
well I think maybe they did I think it
was in 1964 which is the one election
where the Democrats which would who
would have won overwhelmingly anyway did
perfect the whole idea of demonizing the
opponent right the the famous Daisy had
the Tony Schwartz did with the little
girl picking the flowers and then as you
point out in the book what's so
wonderful about it is Barry Goldwater is
never mentioned isn't all the
connections are implied but the
long-term implication of that ad was to
hold out the hope in both parties that
you could nuke your opponent with a
single ad now it's happened there have
been answered have been very very
damaging wet boats Swift boats but not
nearly as damaging I think so if votes
only ran once I mean then it was picked
up by the media and the whole question
was it wasn't the ad so much as the
question the two devastating ads in 2000
yeah that was certainly one Willie
Horton in 1988 but the two devastating
ads in in 2004 with John Kerry saying to
camera I voted for it before I voted
against it which established him as a
flip-flopper and then the windsurfing ad
which made it meadow or yes at the same
point in defense of John Kerry's
windsurfing and this is maybe the only
defense of windsurfing that will ever be
uttered by me or anyone else close to
politics in the next 20 years so listen
carefully wasn't it going windsurfing an
authentic John Kerry moment and wasn't
there an element and I spent a lot of
time with Kerry as you did in 2004 there
was a lot of John Kerry trying not to be
Al Gore and that Al Gore's consultants
told them where to do and how to
vacation
John Kerry would to say I would go
windsurfing now I'm gonna go windsurfing
you know what he could have gotten away
with windsurfing but he had to lay down
a predicate and he could have
successfully combated the Swift Boat
adds he had to lay down a predicate and
and and it was this that he was a tough
guy you don't establish that you're a
tough guy by using the word strong 17
times in your acceptance speech the way
you establish that you're a tough guy is
starting from the very beginning of the
general election campaign which began on
the ungodly early moment in March and
April you show that you're willing to
confront the people who disagree with
you you go down and speak to the
Southern Baptist Convention or to Jerry
Falwell Liberty University you take a
bus tour through Alabama and Mississippi
because even though you know you're not
going to win those states you welcome
audiences town meetings where people get
up in your face so then you can tell
them what you believe and you establish
your strength and when it comes time you
know for the mockery for the Swift Boat
ads and and for the windsurfing ads if
you've established that you're a serious
person it's much harder for those things
to work the Kerry campaign from the
beginning didn't place enough value on
the candidate as a component in the
campaign you know when you listen to
them you've heard this Walter yeah when
you when you listen to the consultants
talking about why they were so slow to
respond to the Swift Boat ads in
nineteen in in August of 2004 they
always talk about having not having
enough money to go up on the air but
they had John Kerry John Kerry could
have called you know Bill O'Reilly and
said look put me on oh you know and and
and and I'll debate these guys he could
have he could have made himself the
center of it as he had in past campaigns
but they didn't do that well isn't part
of it as you point out in the book that
there was the fear of bringing up the
other side of John Kerry's Vietnam
service the very courageous testimony
before the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee this to me was the most
outrageous thing
campaign in the spring of 2004 members
of his staff suggested that he embrace
his testimony which was then 33 years
old he just did it this past you know
there's a couple of weeks ago on the
anniversary on the anniversary they
wanted him to go go on the anniversary
of his testimony and re-establish the
fact that he was opposed to the war and
this is why and he stood by with his
comrades who admitted to atrocities in
Vietnam and this is why because the the
members of the staff understood that
sooner or later the Republicans were
going to bring it up now this happened
to coincide with Abu Ghraib coming up
and he made a couple of you know
boilerplate statements we have to
investigate this and so on and so forth
but he also the the what the consultants
did was they had focus groups they had
one in Arkansas and what came out of
those focus groups was they
focus-grouped Abu Ghraib I mean can you
believe that they they well III laughs
but I should have shuddered you know
what came out of it was that people were
disturbed by the images that they had
seen they were they they were worried
about how we were gonna be seen in the
world but ultimately you know the people
in the focus groups believed that it was
justified that we should use whatever
means necessary to get information out
of the terrorists and the consultants
told me that they were unanimous in
their advice to John Kerry not to use
that and so he didn't he didn't mention
it in his acceptance speech he didn't
confront push on at once during their
three debates together and therefore you
know he completely eviscerated his own
heart you know he eviscerated who he was
as a person and as a candidate by not
doing it one of the reasons why I've
always thought that consultants are
treated very terribly by the political
press is they are also our best sources
and in many cases our best friend and
our best yeah we have you know many in
common and the poor
here is that very difficulty of the fact
that on one hand unlike the total true
believers invested in the candidates the
consultants have perspective they can
often compare our presidential or a
Senate race to other presidential or
Senate races birth the same point
isn't there something seductive in being
trapped in that sort of element that
you're exchanging information because
you and I am a consultants have the big
picture and the poor candidate and the
poor loyal aides the David Wade's of
this world we only believe in the
candidate and this particular campaign
that's absolutely true and it is really
insidious I mean there is nothing more
sexy for a political journalist than to
have a conversation with a consultant
who bad-mouths his candidate and that
happens continually as you know that
happened to me with some of Kerry's
consultants not Bob Shrum by the way Bob
Shrum is one of the most honorable
consultants when it comes to that but
yeah that's true but we have to we have
to keep our sense of perspective about
these things and I wish I want to
stipulate for the record both of you and
I have been admirable and doing we give
it our best but you know the other thing
is this political candidates are the
kids who sat up in the front of the room
in high school
political consultants and political
journalists are the people who sat in
the back room and shot spit balls at the
people in the front of the room we have
a much greater natural affinity with the
irreverent ironic often hilarious you
know political consultants than we do
with you know the candidates who say
rather than a policy of Family Values
and so there is that that that natural
affinity you know I try and transcend it
as you do by going out and watching
these guys that's the best way to
transcend it to actually see them
interact with people to see them doing
their work so that we can make a
judgment on it rather than having our
judgments made by consultants too many
times too many journalists especially
colonists like us don't go out and do
the road work I would begin to go into
withdrawal I would start frothing at the
mouth if I didn't but but also it has
its utility but the problem of course
and going down to congressional and
Senate races I was just in Ohio is that
both the demands of TV time means that
they are closeted ninety percent of
their time doing fundraising right or
the the since no consultant has ever
made a buck off watching a candidate go
door to door with a bunch of door
knockers the number of times when
candidates actually interact with voters
as opposed to retire to TV studios to
film the ads that they've raised they're
writing our fewer and fewer so often you
can go somewhere and nothing is
happening except offstage let me be
optimistic here for a second I think
that the consultants are beginning to
understand the following principle that
the utility of of TV ads has diminished
markedly with the arrival of the clicker
you know and people are just turning
these off and I think that as we move
from the television era to the
television / internet era politics is
going to have to become more interactive
it's going to be a lot less or rating
and a lot more conversing and they're
going to have to find different ways to
communicate with us in different excuses
- to make the large amounts of money
that they make one of the things about
the large amounts of money which is
really interesting to me is to what
extent is the control of the consultants
having to do also for their financial
self-interest as you indicate in the
book and I've written about your average
media consultant and very few donors
know this mix 9 to 15 percent of the
media by that means if you give a
to a candidate 15 cents or nine cents
immediately goes to the consultant
before ad goes up on the Democratic side
right on the Republican side instead of
treating them as saviors they treat him
as employees and they get paid a flat
rate going into the campaign it was
certainly true of the two the last two
Bush campaigns so but fortunes have been
made doing this and it's really amazing
you know they you know the the the one
of the more interesting things about the
Swift Boat Business in 2004 is that you
know at the various you know meetings
that were held at Harvard and the
University of Pennsylvania afterwards
where the consultants discussed the
campaigns people like Shrum said that
they didn't have the money to go up on
the air immediately to counter this the
Swift Boat campaign because they didn't
bust out of the federal spending limits
well they wound up with 15 million
dollars in the bank what were they
thinking exactly and I was at the
Harvard seminar at the Kennedy School we
both were a number of key thought and
what I remember them saying is we
thought we might be raising a little
money on the internet but we weren't
sure so we didn't want to go into debt
they raised a hundred and eighty million
dollars between March and August right
over the Internet mostly right and you
know and and the interesting thing is
that when you see Kerry talking about
this now he doesn't get it either he
still thinks he still thinks that the
reason why he didn't respond to the
Swift Boat ads was because they stayed
within the federal spending limits and
that's that's nuts
because for those keeping score at home
by self-funding his campaign to the tune
of five million dollars in November in
December that kept 2003 they kept John
Kerry alive he was able to he was able
to go over this federal spending limits
because he didn't get federal matching
funds yeah in the primaries and that was
in the primaries he did have one or two
ads that actually were important and
they were they were killer positives you
know the famous del Sandusky ad where
you know one of his Swift Boat
but he's sang his praises and said this
is a good American it is the most
powerful ad I saw in the 2000 of ad in
the 2004 cycle I think it is singularly
why John Kerry won the Iowa caucus you
know and the funny thing is that Matthew
Dowd who was you know Bush's chief
strategist in the campaign said to me
when when I saw that ad I thought we
were in trouble he said why didn't they
keep on doing things like that well the
reason why was that the ad was done by
Jim Margolis who was pushed out of the
campaign by Shrum divine and Donnellan
and they've never used that del sandusky
ad or the other ads that Margolis had
done earlier again Joe I want to come
back to the whole a point in which the
reasons why John Kerry changed
consultants from success to lack of
success but we'll take a quick break
first afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with Joe Klein
and Walter Shapiro in a moment
Saturday May 6th from Maryland's capital
city book TVs live coverage of the
Annapolis book festival begins at 11:30
a.m. Eastern speakers include
Christopher Hitchens contributing editor
at Vanity Fair and author of the book
the short war Donvan not a junior a
member of three Pulitzer prize-winning
investigative teams at the New York
Times and the Miami Herald during the
afternoon conversations with founder and
president of the internet security
adviser and author of the book corporate
espionage IRA Winkler CNN terrorism
analyst and fellow at the new American
Foundation Peter Bergen and Mark mal
seed co-author of the Google story the
Annapolis Book Festival Saturday May 6
beginning at 11:30 a.m. Eastern on
c-span 2's book TV
Robert Remini author and scholar of
history for over five decades shares the
triumphs and failures of the people's
house from his book the house the
history of the House of Representatives
live Sunday May 7 on in depth beginning
at noon the former University of
Illinois professor has authored new
books on historical greats such as
Andrew Jackson Henry Clay and John
Quincy Adams join our live three-hour
discussion
Sunday May 7 at noon as book TVs in
depth welcomes ruffed remedy on c-span 2
afterwards with Joe Klein and Walter
Shapiro continues Joe you were talking
about the easing out of Jim Margolis who
made the most effective ads for John
Kerry in the campaign and we also talked
about money a bit and the percentage of
the ad buy wasn't wasn't the easing out
of Jim Margolis to some extent using the
greed of consultants to get someone out
of the way yeah it was I mean it's
difficult to figure out exactly what
happened there but if the there was a
dispute between Margolis who was getting
you know who had started off getting all
of the the money and then agreed to go
5050 with Shrum divine and Donnellan and
from divine and Donnellan wanted to get
three-quarters of the money apparently
and Margolis was balking at that but you
know in the end it was all about the
money and when you talk to other people
in the campaign they were you know
astonished and disgusted what by how all
of the consultants were so obsessed with
with the money then none of that kind of
stuff on the on the Republican side I
mean you know on the Republican side
what they did was this first of all
there wasn't one advertising firm doing
all of it there was mark McKinnon former
Democrat who would contract out to
various firms for various ads he would
request you know script proposals and he
would pick and choose and he tried to
spread the wealth around so that
everybody was everybody got a little
something and everybody was kept happy
and this goes back to the theory that
one of the reasons why Republicans do so
well in presidential elections is that
they're just more business oriented and
better businessman
I've got step further is it possible my
theory here grant theory from the host
is the Democratic consultants
traditionally were much more
uncomfortable with working in the off
years for business clients so that they
had to make it big in the even-numbered
years from the political clients while
for most Republicans there I used the
word synergy between their business
clients and their political clients so
the Greek level and the not even greed
just the business practices and the the
fact that Democratic consultants get a
percentage of the by have just become so
ingrained on the Democratic side I don't
know whether that's totally true I mean
it made my theory Dart
it may it may be it may be true for some
of them but going back to Pat Caddell
who really you know established the
business on that on the the Democratic
side when he was working for Carter in
in in in 76 and even before that his
company came Cambridge strategies had
set up a separate company to you know to
deal with corporate clients and so he
later giving us new coke right and and
also David Sawyer had a huge corporate
client base in the 1980s when he was one
of the dominant Democratic consultants
so I think that that you know both sides
work on this but the way the Republicans
do it is really interesting I think that
and Bush is really interesting one
reason why the president is so
fascinating is that of all the recent
politicians that we've covered he seems
less bound by polls than almost anybody
I mean here's a gonna say less bound by
reality than almost and yet well we
could say that too
but you know the you know if he looked
at the polls for Social Security reform
a year ago he would find that most of
people didn't
want to do anything about it immigration
right now he's on the wrong side of the
polls Dubai ports he certainly was and
and now if he were going to follow the
polls he would have a skedaddling out of
Iraq but he doesn't do that on the other
hand he is one of the most focused
groups you know massaged and consulted
candidates that we've ever seen you know
if the 2004 election was was a
one-sentence election and Kerry's
sentence was I voted for it before I
voted against it and Bush's sentence was
you may not agree with me but always
agree with me but you'll always know
where I stand
that was probably the most perfect
focus-grouped sentence in any campaign
it had two components you may not always
agree with me which was consultant knees
for saying oh my god they disagree with
us on almost everything you know if they
don't like this war they don't like this
it may not always agree with me but
you'll always know where I stand which
was Consultant knees for you can't trust
that other guy he's a windsurfer and it
was extremely effective what offends me
as a citizen is that they've taken that
into the White House it's as recent as
last week Karl Rove who is a political
consultant more or less was in charge of
policy and political consultants and
policy makers should look at the world
through different ends of the telescope
policymakers should be looking down the
road to what is going to affect our kids
and what's going to affect the country
in the long term political consultants
think in terms of winning the news cycle
and the message of the week now you have
to have those components when you're
selling a policy but if you don't have
the long-term thinking and the
nitty-gritty management work when it
comes to selling policies which the Bush
administration clearly has not had
you're not going to have success one
quick other theory on that I will end my
theories for this and and and return to
the realm of fact and that is is since I
don't think that there is a moral
difference between Democrat
operatives and Republican operatives I
really think the operative class is the
operative class right and I think to
some extent the difference some of the
differences are their role models the
great Republican hero is of course
Ronald Reagan big broad stroke themes
never worry about the details and the
Democratic hero post candidate is Bill
Clinton a man whose entire presidency
was let's win the news cycle today and
we'll figure out what to do tomorrow
goes by and it actually goes back even
even farther than that I mean you know
Eisenhower was of that same model and
roosevelt franklin roosevelt really is
really was the guy who set the predicate
for the for the democratic party ever
since now what Bill Clinton was trying
to do and what the party is going to
have to do if it wants to succeed is to
move that Roosevelt template into the
information age and and and start
thinking in different ways about
governance breagan has done the
Republican Party a major disservice
though he gave him the simple sentences
but we've now had 30 years of a party
that believes in its soul what Ronald
Reagan said that government isn't part
it you know isn't part of the solution
it's part of the problem now if you
believe that the tendency is as you said
to not not do the difficult management
work of governance you create a
Department of Homeland Security as part
of the permanent campaign it's going to
help you win in 2002 but then you don't
how to figure out how to make the whole
thing mix and match and and be
manageable you know if if you if you
believe that government is part of the
problem not part of the solution
ultimately the results you're going to
get are Hurricane Katrina and the
disaster on the ground in Iraq after
after we after Baghdad fell no I I
mostly agree with you on that and but
let's I just want to go
since I'm conscious of time I just want
to go to the roads not take it
the Mavericks we all have our sneaking
weakness for as reports not sneaking me
because they're interesting and and the
fact is that these are the people who
either don't have consultants because
they are starting their campaign fresh
and really have very little
infrastructure really Howard Dean who
had no money right was this was all
Howard Dean or candidates who have
consultants but the consultants are sort
of co-conspirators which is John McCain
mm with Mike Murphy exactly right
and I'm just wondering what is the
interplay between can those kind of
mavericks and consultants and can they
lead us to a different kind of politics
well I think the biggest thing that
those Mavericks have going for them is
that they speak English it's very rare I
mean you know I don't know whether
you're out there with me in 1980 I was
watching Bob Dole in New Hampshire and a
and a junior high school kid a little a
young girl asks him about his position
on acid rain and he said that bill is in
markup and so you know you were always
I'm always I'm a sucker for people who
speak English but the problem with a
with a maverick campaign is that become
so much a cult of personality that it's
hard to move to the next level with
Howard Dean he starts off with you know
what ultimately was the correct position
on Iraq which was that it was not the
right war for us to be involved in and
Elaine came our communal friend of ours
had this fabulous line which was that we
both have used and you've gotten to
prend
right she said the reason why I hired
Howard Dean was the only Democrat who
was right about the war was that he was
the only Democrat who didn't get a
confidential intelligence briefing from
the CIA so he starts off with that and
then gradually the campaign becomes
about the campaign and you know you
remember it was one of the most euphoric
wonderful campaigns I ever covered but
ultimately Dean's speeches became isn't
this a great crowd aren't we
and I'm just thinking about Dean at the
Iowa 2003 Democratic convention in Des
Moines turning to the crowd in almost a
rock star fashion shouting endlessly
you have the power right which was not
shall we say the substantive part of his
agenda but also even you know and it was
around that same time that Dean goes to
Cooper Union and uses the podium that
Abraham Lincoln used when he said a
house divided against itself cannot
stand
and a podium that politicians have used
to say things of substance ever since
and Dean talks about busting out of the
federal campaign finance limits I
realized at that point that the campaign
was only about process and not about
substance and that's the sort of problem
that Mavericks get into over time what
I've always wondered in the politics is
such a copycat profession that had
somehow John McCain hung on and beaten
george w bush in the 2000 republican nam
south carolina primary and gotten the
nomination every candidate post mccain
would have been why don't we throw off
the consultants and spend five hours on
busses answering questions from
reporters and it was the fact mccain
came so close that had he been
successful even if he had not been a
good president or elected it would have
changed the whole nature by what you run
for president i think that that's true
but I think I also think it's coming but
I have this an utter nightmare if I have
the fantasy that people will start
expecting from politicians in 2008 that
they that they tell us some inconvenient
truths my nightmare is that all over
Washington politicians will get together
with their consultants and say we got to
we got to work up something spontaneous
you know let's let's plan some
spontaneous event and we may be seeing
some of that in 2001 we may be spending
a lot of it but it's still at a point
when you can now spend days on a
presidential campaign
I'm thinking Bush mm doing nothing other
than watching presidential candidates
read something badly from a teleprompter
right the idea that there was a man who
had a plausible shot of being president
mm I want to ask you about 2008 in a
second
sitting on a bus in South Carolina for
four and five hours just answering any
questions imaginable from reporters
McCain had a whole riff about how the
France went wrong because of the death
of all the friend the French leadership
class in the trenches of World War II
and I remember on these preps of McCain
reporters who wanted to change their
batteries or just take a break or just
change their posture would ask the
France question McCain would go off on
this riff with which he believed
sincerely no one could get into print
and we got a ten-minute break without
saying senator I think that's enough
right right you know as I said I think
that we're heading more toward that sort
of politics I think it's inevitable I
think that that even if you had talked
to consultants as you and I do I think
that they're beginning to recognize that
a lot of the stuff that worked through
the television era isn't gonna work
anymore because the public has caught up
with it and they understand that you
know when even when you say you may not
agree with me but you will always know
where I stand that's a market-tested
line it's a somewhat better line then I
voted for it before I voted against it
and that's why George W Bush won but you
can't expect especially at this moment
when the country really has some serious
problems and I think the public knows
about it when you look at the
president's poll numbers when you look
at the right track wrong track poll
numbers people understand that there are
serious problems that we're facing now
and in the future and so I think that
it's entirely possible that they're
going to demand a different kind of
politics in 2008 or at least marginally
so and that those candidates who
continued to try and run the bush 2000
for campaign where the guy never fielded
a single hostile question from a
civilian during the course of the
campaign and had precious few press
press conferences I don't think that's
gonna fly so let's talk about the two
frontrunners in both parties right now
and how they fit into this consultant
spontaneous authentic grid on one hand
Hillary Clinton on the Democratic side
and number two John McCain on the
Republican side John McCain who with
things like his upcoming commencement
address at Jerry Falwell --zz Liberty
University is at least becoming a
slightly different candidate than he was
in 2000 well let's talk about McCain
first first of all I don't mind that
he's going to Liberty University it was
the kind of thing that I just suggested
a little while ago that if John Kerry
had done that sort of stuff and and had
done it you know in a way that
acknowledged the differences and and and
fielded their questions and might have
worked for him what I do mind about John
McCain is his changing his positions on
core issues for him a core John McCain
value was fiscal responsibility he
opposed the Bush tax cuts and now all of
a sudden he's voting for the Bush tax
cuts and with a sort of Bill Clinton s
explanation that I've never voted for a
tax hike in my life and not to make the
tax cuts permanent would raise our taxes
yeah except for the fact that as McCain
knows and has argued in the past that of
to vote for that tax cut is to vote for
a tax increase for our kids he knows
that and if he's going to become a
candidate who who abandons his core
values than people like me and you and
the public I think are going to start
viewing his candidacy more skeptically
and also I think a couple of other
things about McCain first of all
Republicans aren't going to buy that
they know who he is and finally and most
importantly McCain isn't going to buy it
you know he is he is sufficiently
unconventional and candid as a human
being that he's going to get really
bored in a couple of months of being
trying to be a conventional Republican I
don't think that that has a long or very
successful shelf life
what about authenticity and the
Democratic side of the equation well
that leads us to Hillary and I wrote a
column about this a year ago and I stand
by it I mean look a couple of things
first of all as we know she is a very
cautious and controlled politician who
is who's spontaneous public moments can
be counted on maybe one or two fingers
the exact opposite of her husband by the
way second of all the first woman who
succeeds in running for the presidents
he's going to have to be a political
genius she's going to have to deal with
the fact that likability warmth has
become the most important variable in
any given election warm beats cold every
time and when you have to cold fish like
George HW Bush and Michael Dukakis the
slightly warmer one wins the only
exception to this rule is Richard Nixon
at the same time yeah Richard Nixon
Hubert Humphrey was certainly a
violation difference of all but then the
country was a total mess at that point
and so there was a reason for the one
exception to the rule but the you know
what what what the first woman who
succeeds that this is going to have to
show is toughness and strength and
likability at the same time I don't know
that Senator Clinton has those skills
what I expect is this
I expect that it's going to be something
like 2004 and I can be very very wrong
she's going to come roaring into Iowa
kind of like Howard Dean did way ahead
in the polls with all kinds of money
with all kinds of endorsements and then
we're going to have an election for
about three weeks and there's going to
be one very difficult to answer question
on the table what's he going to do you
ran healthcare for him what are you
what is he gonna do in your in your
presidency what is Bill Clinton's role
going to be and wasn't he already
president and then there'll be one layer
down this question which is the
presidency is our most precious public
institution so we want it to be
something that we keep on handing back
and forth between these two defective
families and I think that if mrs.
Clinton can come up with you know
sufficient answers to those questions
and show some humanity in the process
she may have a shot barring that though
you know both of these frontrunners I
could safely say right now may not be
the frontrunner in the end I know I mean
to some extent the entire game of
politics is annointing candidates as
frontrunners when nobody's paying
attention then being shocked when they
cease to become frontrunners when voters
are actually paying attention right I
mean it's up you know I remember in
December of 2003 the night that Al Gore
endorsed Howard Dean a CNN anchor asked
me in all seriousness is it over Joe and
I said well no we kind of have to have
an election people kind of have to vote
first before it's you know and and
that'll be the beginning the other
interesting thing about 2008 there's
another rule that we that we live by
political journalists and that is that
governors make better candidates than
senators do because they're they don't
use phrases like working both sides of
the aisle or that bills in markup you
know they're their executives they're
leaders but you know I've had a series
of conversations early on with some of
the governors who who are thinking about
doing this like Mark Warner and Tom
Vilsack both it you know terrific guys
potentially excellent candidates but
they don't know national security and I
think that it may well be possible that
after September 11th the fact that
senators do know national security many
of them will work more to their
advantage and the fact that governor's
don't have a detailed knowledge of
overseas problems may work to their
disadvantage so we may see a rebalancing
2008 what you also have is to go to
former governors who also are in the
United States Senate who are thinking
running George Allen on the Republican
side and Evan Bayh on the Democratic
side who well they may have deficiencies
as candidates they do offer that twofer
yeah that's that's absolutely right and
I'd say that Allen's getting a lot of
word-of-mouth here now and Evan Bayh is
generally considered a stiff but who
knows until we actually go out and see
these things you know I have sufficient
love of the process as I know you do
that I can be patient I don't have to I
don't you know I don't have opinions
right now about who's gonna win this and
which is the total frustration of every
dinner party I'm at FC they asked for
total certainty and the whole beauty of
American politics for those parts of
American politics that have not been
scripted and syncopated to death is that
we don't know that a hundred thousand
Democrats and a hundred thousand
Republicans in Iowa will have a lot more
to say about who the nominees are than
most of the dinner parties of you and I
will go do for the next two years you
know my feeling is now let's just sit
back and enjoy the thing and watch it
and hope that along the road we'll get
to see some of these guys and women have
turnip damo moments like Harry Truman
did what were you saying
if if the candidates came to you after
reading this book or if candidates read
this book and wanted to draw conclusions
from it about how they should deal with
their own consultants that they will
have to have to run for president what
message do they help would you like a
Republican or a Democrat to draw from it
to thine own self be true I mean the
only recommendation I make in the book
is that each candidate have someone on
board to act as a better angel to remind
him or her who they really are so that
they don't get overwhelmed by the
consultants who come to them with all
this science all this polling data and
focus group data
be yourself and don't be afraid to tell
us some inconvenient truths and the
problem if you have any theories of
Wendy you can't tell the American people
inconvenient truths started was it the
president in whose White House I serve
Jimmy Carter who told the American
people a lot of inconvenient truths and
is remembered mostly as a very
successful former president I think that
that you know the malaise speech in
which Carter going doing great D which I
go into now something in which Carter
never used the word malaise was was a
failure ultimately although it's a
wonderful speech when you read it was a
failure ultimately not because of its
pessimism because it said to the
American people not that we have to get
get our act together and sacrifice in
order to become energy independent which
essentially was you know a good part of
the message it was your to down on
yourselves you're too pessimistic and
that kind of message will never work
with the American people you're
alienated that won't work what will work
is is if a politician comes to us and
say this is a terrific country and we've
met challenges before we got this big
challenge out there now we may have to
pay a little bit extra for gasoline now
try and make it up to you in other ways
but in the long term your kids will have
a much better life and will be much more
secure if we don't have to depend on
those Saudis for you know for our
gasoline that kind of thing is more
likely to work than coming to the
American people and tell them telling
them that they're depressed at the same
part I was in the Carter White House
during that time and I remember reading
being forced to read because I had a
right
we saw response second third day
speeches on them after the famous
quarter speech reading the letters from
ordinary citizens that came into the
White House and there was an outpouring
a mail in this pre email era just trying
to convey that Carter did speak to
something that they were hearing
something from a president
from a leader that they had not heard
before and I think the speech itself was
quite good and it was the execution of
firing the entire cabinet afterwards
which is a lot as you point out in the
book the handiwork of a political
consultant Pat Caddell but you know I
think that now you know George Bush had
a similar opportunity and he didn't take
it right after September 11th if he
never asked anything of us except to go
shopping and if he had asked something
of us and if he had made this I hesitate
to use the word crusade but a national
crusade to become energy independence or
an energy independent or whatever I
think he'd have a much more successful
presidency right now if he had brought
all of us along on the war and made the
war something that we all had to be part
of rather than something that we have
those troops over there do